le monde a découvert son visage aux
côtés du golfeur thomas ce viol en
octobre dernier pour la journée ryder
cup au golf national va-t-il de claisse
17 ans fait partie des golfeuses
françaises les plus doués de sa
génération
l'envers du décor et plus studieux la
jeune yvelinoise intégrer une section
sport étude de la fédération française
depuis cinq ans le premier truc à faire
on vérifie l'élément en commun donc
entre ces toxines ans et son réducteur
associés c'est caractéristique de quoi
dans une solution je reste dans cette
classe aménagée au golf national
mathilde suit des cours aux petits
groupes de quatre élèves
la sportive passe en moyenne cinq heures
par jour loin des greens pour préparer
son bac scientifique
j'ai la partie des agents statut de
sportif au niveau de l' éducation
nationale de passements vacante deux ans
donc j'ai séparer les matières est donc
ça facilite la tâche un peu ça me donne
plus de temps pour faire les deux pour
gérer les deux une fois les cours
terminés direction les terrains de golf
l'athlète qui a commencé ce sport à 5
ans à villennes-sur-seine tape la balle
une vingtaine d'heures chaque semaine
j'ai un bac faut que je fasse des études
après c'est d'abord le golfe et ouais je
préfère passer du temps à m'entraîner à
travailler le soir au golf un peu sans
que ce qu'on veut par rapport à soi
les sessions incluse dans le programme
sport études sont encadrés par un coach
national
elles doivent lui permettre d'accéder
aux gros tournois mondiaux pour
atteindre le haut niveau elles sont
obligées d'augmenter la quantité de
l'entraînement et
c'est pour ça que cette structure a été
créée un entraînement intensif sur le
plan golfique dans tous les facteurs de
performance ont à la fois sur la partie
technique sur la dimension physique
donc tout est organisé autour de ça pour
mettre là je la joue dedans les dans les
meilleures conditions
voilà plus de vingt doigts très bien
je pense que ça va être beaucoup les
filles qui sont pas une structure comme
nous je sais qu'elles ont beaucoup de
mal surtout en terminale du call back
c'est vraiment dur de concilier les deux
et nous bah ouais on y arrive bien à
grâce à sa savane eu plus de facilités
pour m'entraîner elle progressait à
mathilde envisage maintenant de partir
aux usa dans une faculté pour continuer
à jouer sur les deux tableaux le golf et
les études avec un objectif en tête
participer aux jo de 2024 qui seront
organisés à saint quentin en yvelines